[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente le 29
décembre 2023 l'Afrique du Sud a déposé
devant la Cour internationale de justice
en vertu de la convention de 1948 pour
la prévention et la répression du crime
de génocide une requête contre Israël
concernant les exactions commises par
son gouvernement d'extrême droite contre
la population palestinienne de Gaza le
11 janvier 2024 les plédroiries de la
République sud-africaine ont fait
l'objet d'un scandaleux boycotte des
médias occidentaux et français il
s'agissait pourtant d'un événement
historique à la porté politique et
juridique inédit l'État dont la
légitimité initiale est fondée sur la
conscience du génocide commis contre les
Juifs par l'Allemagne nazi et ses
complices et aujourd'hui accusé de le le
reproduire contre les Palestiniens et
les palestiniennes les gouvernements
occidentaux qui n'ont de cesse de donner
des leçon de démocratie et de droits
humains au reste du monde font preuve de
complaisance à son égard quand il ne lui
apportent pas comme les États-Unis
d'Amérique un soutien militaire et
financier c'est l'Afrique du Sud la
nation arc-en-ciel qui a subi
l'esclavage la colonisation et
dont le peuple a consclit sa liberté en
au terme du très longue et très dur
lutte de libération nationale c'est ce
pays africain qui a sauvé notre honneur
à tous et toutes en défendant à la fois
la cause du peuple palestinien celle du
droit international et de l'humanité
toute entière nous lui en sommes
profondément reconnaissant et
reconnaissante à Gaza expliqué une de
ses avocates se déroule le premier
génocide de l'histoire dont les victim
diffusent en temps réel leur propre
destruction dans l'espoir désespéré et
jusqu'à présent vain de voir le m faire
quelque chose si elle veut être en
cohérence avec ses valeurs la France
doit urgemment emboîer le pas à
l'Afrique du Sud comme l'ont déjà fait
plus de 50 pays dans le monde elle doit
soutenir la requête sud-africaine qui
demande notamment à la Cour
internationale de Justice d'enjoindre le
gouvernement israélien à suspendre
immédiatement ses opérations militaires
elle doit également appliquer au niveau
national et européen des sanctions qui
s'imposent Monsieur le Premier Ministre
l'histoire nous regarde elle ne sera pas
tendre avec celles et ceux qui savaient
et n'ont rien fait plus jamais ça pour
personne je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Stéphane séjourné ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires
étrangères
merci merci madame la présidente madame
la députée auonau le 7 octobre dernier
Israël a subi une attaque terroriste
barbare 1200 morts des mutilations des
viols des assassinats d'enfants les
civils israéliens ont été visés pour
ceux qu'ils
sont 41 français sont morts dans ces
conditions atroce nous leur rendrons
hommage le 7 février et trois encore de
nos compatriotes sont a Tage à Gaza et
nous faisons tout pour les en sortir
qu'avez-vous dit en réaction à ces
crimes terroristes je vous cite le Hamas
est un groupe de résistance qui se
définit comme tel madame auonau c'est
scandale madame
auono le Président de la République lui
a toujours tenu une position d'équilibre
je vous la rappelle condamner le
terroriste ce que vous n'arrivez
toujours pas à faire madame
vrez un cesser le feu immédiat pour
permettre de garantir les souffrances
des Palestiniens rétablir un horizon
politique pour avancer vers de ét minist
monsieur le ministre 2 secondes est-ce
que vous pourriez faire silence et
écouter la s'il vous plaît je vous en
remercie mais vous ne choisissez pas vos
réponses ils ne choisissent pas leurs
questions monsieur le ministreelle la
position de la France madame
obonau rétablir un horizon politique
pour avancer vers deux états et ce sujet
sera au cœur des discussions de la
réunion du Conseil de sécurité que je
présiderai mardi prochain à New York
pour ce qui est de la Cour
internationale de justice puisque c'est
votre question j'y
[Applaudissements]
Allis nous disons fermement aux
Israéliens le respect du droit s'impose
à tous les frappes systématiques à Gaza
doivent cesser mais les mots madame
auonau ont un sens les mots ont un sens
et accuser l'État juif de génocide c'est
frangir un seuil
moral on ne peut exploiter la notion de
génocide à des fins politique c'est
notre position constante nous l'avons
dit quand la Russie a utilisé ce
justificatif pour justifier
l'injustifiable sa guerre en Ukraine
merci beaucou alors en conclusion madame
la Président j'ai été interrompu en
conclusion nous n'avons pas de leçon à
recevoir de votre parti vous n'êtes pas
au clair ni sur le Hermas ni sur
Gaza merci Monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
Ministre madame obonau s'il vous plaît